I carefully remember mine dating up I  know you're like the perfect girl and no  we just not bad I just feel so right one  another than that oh I like you oh you  got a little something right now  oh no I could you know what I think that  we are gonna be together for a while I'm  tellin ya  oh-ho look at those chairs this was not  what I was meant to be doing good I'm  not a chipmunk I'm a human  oh oh you use you ain't never gonna let  go I'm never gonna let go donkey you  wanna go oh I don't think you can be any  cuter listen I think that we should I  like you you and all you should go on  another day after this I'm not going to  plan it we're gonna plan it a big thumbs  up for this date my friend a big thumbs  up for this site two thumbs up one two  two thumbs up for you I swear not many  guys get those but you do this has been  so fun but I have to go call me